the jurogan experience how did you
become the undertaker
so so that's that's vince's brainchild
so i went to
another company wcw where i was mean
mark callus
and right there check that young stud
out right there
that's terrifying isn't it
all right guys hobbit yeah uh just
uh that's uh yeah we can take that down
anytime
[Laughter]
so so so i go there
and uh i was about i was there about
eight or nine months
and uh my contract was coming up and
i go i go in to renegotiate my contract
and they were like look
you're great athlete kid but no one's
ever gonna pay money to watch you
wrestle
like i'm just looking for a little bit
of bump right a little bump in my
paycheck i'm not looking
for the mega deal i'm just looking for a
little bit of bump
now we're going to give you the same
deal for a year
i mean you just you know you do great
things in the ring but no one's ever
going to pay money to see you wrestle
did they give you advice on how to get
someone to pay
oh wow that was it that was it
so like okay my ceiling i know where my
ceiling is here right
so uh just through
you know a few different people i get
connected with some people in the in the
wwwf at the times wwe now
and i had a match coming up my hip was
already bad
at that point even back then yeah i i it
got much worse but i was already limping
and uh and i just heard it
when we got vince you know they said all
right you know they've got a
pay-per-view
just watching work you know so vince
watches me work and i'm calm like i'm
i'm
you know talking to my buddy bruce i'm
like bruce my hip is jacked he goes just
go out there vince is going to be
watching right so i'm working with a guy
by name lex luger
went out there and did what i could i
sucked i mean i was you know i was i was
physically
you know i was physically not able
really to to go
the way i could go and vince wasn't
impressed you know he's like
okay he's you know he's running the mill
fortunately guys like uh you know paul
heyman and
and uh and bruce pritchard you know they
believed in me
and they kind of kept pushing for me to
get this meeting with vince
and finally i did and he calls me i got
to go to his house right
so i go to his house vince's house like
[ __ ] he couldn't it's nice
it's [ __ ] where's he living he's in
connecticut man he's so
you're in control yeah so i'm not being
called to the castle oh dude
yeah and that's what i'm thinking right
because most people go to you know the
office
to the towers there in stanford right
and i'm thinking [ __ ] i'm going to the
house
i got this [ __ ] right so
i i go in and i have the meeting meeting
goes for about an hour and a half and
you know and this is you know
there's a lot of does he have a butler
but
he i know he had a housekeeper
he imagined there'd be a dude with a
british accent from the door
i never saw him just ripped yeah right
you had to be
everybody everybody's jack that works
for ritz but uh
so i go i go there and uh you know
granted we do some hokey [ __ ]
it is what it is and they really at that
point had some really
really [ __ ] goofy characters and
uh you know so that we're having this
we're sitting in his living room and he
goes well
mark you got to be hidden talents you
know other than you know wrestling do
you do anything you know and i'm trying
to be funny and not nervous
and well you know i was sitting in the
shower pretty good and as soon as i said
it right
i'm like oh [ __ ] i shouldn't have said
that i'm gonna be [ __ ]
i'm gonna be [ __ ] shower guys you
know some something silly right
shower guys yeah i'm gonna have to see
you know i'm thinking
i'm like oh [ __ ] i should not have said
that right and then i'm like i'm kidding
you know i'm trying to clear the air
right away
i'm just kidding i can't sing not you
know and
you know he's got the look right he
knows how you know he can read people
and he's like
really no i can't i can't
so i got this long meeting and i at the
end of the meeting he goes well
we don't have anything for you right now
i'm thinking
oh [ __ ] i guess i guess i overplayed my
hand here because i'd already give
wcw my notice that i was leaving i like
[ __ ] i kind of
i'm this is what i'm thinking in my head
right i was like he invited me to the
house he's gonna hire me right
so you guys i see you guys down the road
so now i'm sitting there like [ __ ] i got
no job
and uh anyway so one day
uh it's getting getting close to
thanksgiving
and they start doing this promotion
where they've got this giant
[ __ ] egg have you heard this story oh
yeah the
gobbledygoo the gobbley cougar right so
we do a pay-per-view around surviv
around thanksgiving it's called survivor
series so this year
this particular year is 1990 they're
gonna
yeah there it is uh they've got this
giant egg on the set on the tv
every week and i'm sitting there
thinking to myself
holy [ __ ] i'm gonna be i'm now now i've
gone from shower guy now i think i'm
gonna be eggman right
[ __ ] i'm gonna have to you know i'm
trying to grow my hair out and
i said [ __ ] he's gonna make me shave my
head i'm gonna shave my eyebrows
i'm gonna be [ __ ] eggman oh and i'm a
nervous wreck
right so one day i'm sitting at home
phone rings i get up and go answer it
because we didn't have cell phones back
then right so
hello he goes is uh is this the
undertaker
i was like undertaker
undertaker undertaker hidden egg man
[ __ ] undertaker that's pretty [ __ ]
cool
yeah yeah this is undertaker yeah and it
was vince and that was how he introduced
the character to me
he called you up and asked you if you're
the undertaker yeah
and i had no clue to what it was and wow
and uh i said yeah yeah
i'm the undertaker because i knew it
wasn't eggman and everything had to be
better than eggman he wasn't singing the
shower yeah he wasn't singing the shower
guy it wasn't eggman
flew me up to connecticut the next day
showed me the storyboards
and the character the original character
is based
on an old western undertaker you know
the two guys in main street they had the
[ __ ] shootout
one guy loses undertaker comes out
measures them
does the box well that was the original
likeness
and and the name the undertaker and uh
he just never found the guy
he had had it for years i guess so why
did he send you away the first time
when you went well he didn't he at the
time he didn't have a spot for me but he
was thinking
but he was thinking and then it kind of
dawned on him that he had that character
and he just needed a big guy with no
personality
[Laughter]
he needed to go you know there was void
of personality to do the deal and
uh and he gave it to me and uh there's
my debut right there
that's november of 1990 and i was six
years old and i was [ __ ] my pants
how were you this was the scariest thing
you could imagine for a six-year-old
you know you're watching all these you
know there was some guy in a chicken
suit that came out of that egg to show
you how silly things were back then so
it had our attention
and then all of a sudden this guy comes
out and he's like half dead and you
don't know what's going on and he's
scary
and dominant with anything yeah the the
thing was
was dominant but this is the era of
everything
i mean you could tell this guy's in
bright pink and
so that's coco beware yeah he's wearing
some hot yoga pants yes
you know i mean you know that guy had a
parrot on his shoulder when he came to
the ring
did he yeah right was it a parrot yeah
yeah
frankie catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience